what about you guys do you think there's
any other things to look out by the red
flags with men so the the main thing is
how do they talk about their ex or if
they have any generalizations about
women as a whole if you have someone who
it just seems bitter about all women so
that was one second one was similar to
what you said I've just asked them how I
asked them about their mother like if
they're very caring and speak very
fondly of them other chances are good to
women generally yeah chances are that's
a really really good test I think I need
to be very careful today so the reason
that tinder is bad is because it
immediately brands whatever interaction
you are having with the person under the
guise of tinder like how did you meet or
we met on tinder that's the guy from
tinder you are rated below anybody even
the worst person who comes through on
any of the preferential medium the worst
person I Instagram is rated above the
best person on tinder as my dad would
say with regards to the tinder thing
you're looking for a streak of piss in a
pile of [ __ ] I see I was gonna say
diamond-in-the-rough birth
ladies and gentlemen welcome back Johnny
and Youssef from propane fitness calm
and it is finally time for relationships
104
the instinct including the Instagram for
this is the episode which is most likely
to get me in trouble and make people
cross to rustle Jimmy's do you think
because we're revealing the funnel the
funnel will work better or worse as a
result I think I need to be very careful
today no I think we should go full Louie
through and just ask him about their
fine
so tell us about something I would say
Krishna this is very insensitive way of
approaching relationship what do you say
to those people so I think the funnel is
gonna be more effective I don't think
anyway so relationships 101 102 and 103
all charted in the top fifty worldwide
on iTunes so thank you very much make
sure that you share this episode because
we want to do the same again only just
think like what did I say on those
episode Chris is like celebrating we
just well you've just got severe
potential regret like you don't know
what you said yeah
anyway so we talked about setting rules
and guidelines in a relationship how to
find a good partner then we spoke about
cheating and how to get over
relationships and today it's how to be
single in this room behind aunty
relationships 101 no because like how to
be single includes I guess screening for
potential part so we're in or only Jen
acquisition and the rest conversion was
operations product delivery yes exactly
that's exactly correct this is front end
it is well this is this is you although
apart from the fact that in but you but
somehow also me
in the assumption is being single
doesn't mean choosing the hermit life it
means single with with the oils of
acquisition not necessarily well yeah
the goal of acquisition but what you
term that acquisition into is it
long-term business is it short-term
business on it is it single transaction
so what are we assuming so is the funnel
mainly good for short-term stuff look so
did the funnel the funnel that we're
going to bring up in a little bit is is
not all that this podcast is going to be
about so that so that quit is intensely
disappointing right I will explain
because everyone's gonna be wondering
what the [ __ ] is an Instagram fun I've
been thinking about actually let's not
tell them we'll just keep it we'll just
keep it keep just open loop no I'm
kidding that might as well I'm gonna get
out okay so I mean think about this for
ages cuz I knew that it was gonna it was
gonna happen all right
an Instagram funnel is a particular way
to do lead generation for dating now the
way that I've kind of tried to
conceptualize it can we define a lead I
was just about us up and then I thought
our best time interval is in focus on
yeah you need to finally do it okay its
new customer acquisition
its pre customer so a leader someone who
is within your circle sphere of
awareness but hasn't yet bought
something from you
the reason we're thinking in these terms
is because we've been very much in the
depths of rearranging a product offering
from multiple small cheap offerings
compared to five or ten high-end I
should clarify that you're talking about
internet marketing
we are internet marketing but there are
many great parcels loads of parallel
it's a first level of expression some
kind of interests I mean what are the
only two things that you need to do an
internet marketing really when it comes
to front end you want lead gen in
conversions I'm alright I'll take that
always so a logical would be a reader of
your website or someone who is
your email list or someone who has seen
your post on Facebook and then a
customer's already someone who has paid
you for some there's also a step between
that which is prospect so lead prospect
customer or client okay well I mean it
in this context though it's someone
who's moved away move more towards
engaging in with with you in something
well I'm just gonna whatever that may be
let's reset so the way that I've tried
to conceptualize it is that everybody
you would be surprised by how many
people are appropriate for you and how
many people you were appropriate for but
you don't have sufficient exposure and I
think that a lot of that actually comes
from simply presenting yourself to them
in the best possible light now for some
people they may be very good
face-to-face or they might be really
good dancers for instance like if you're
a guy who's a good dancer
or a girl who's a good dancer you can
walk into a nightclub and you'll lead
janna your dance moves like because
people are noticing that's the yeah
that's exactly the Macarena exact I've
seen yourself do some real damage with
that serious leaning up so my point is
that everybody needs a domain of
competence in which they look like they
have a particularly high degree of value
that basically gets you through the door
and I think what this leads onto quite
nicely is my criticism about tinder
which I think both of you guys know and
this is not the strategy that I use
anymore but it was one I used about five
years ago and the way that is best the
way that I think is best to use tinder
is just run with tinder first so the
reason that tinder is bad is because it
immediately brands whatever interaction
you are having with the person under the
guise of tinder like how did you meet
or we met on tinder that's the guy from
tinder you are rated below anybody even
the worst person who comes through on
any other preferential medium your
starting the race with a
broken ankle or like intranasal
absolutely yeah and it just Mars the the
rest of the exchange because through no
fault of your own but it's just because
every other guy or girl that you're
prospectors seeing on tinder is possibly
a creep or is from a pool of people that
are you can't send dick pics can you
burn up but there's that kind of thing
where it's like you just get creeped
does it's your own tender telling to
have a casual conversation D there's an
end in mind if there is there is which
that so itself is kind of good but as my
dad would say with regards to the tinder
thing you're looking for a streak of
piss in a pile of [ __ ] I don't see I was
gonna say diamond-in-the-rough Bertha
pile of [ __ ] so I think tinder tinder
really for that so an alternative for
this and this particularly works well if
you're going away on holiday again I
don't want to come across as the
transactional sex guy but if you need to
try and find yourself some companionship
with a constitution guy
and if you need to find yourself some
companionship while you're going away I
think this is not too much strategy so
onto tinder need to pay for tinder gold
then you need to be able to move your
location to where it is that you're
gonna go pop yourself into there
determine your range tighten the range
in so that you are well within taxi
distance of wherever it is that you're
sting so you don't like you're not gonna
travel to the other side of God knows
where then as you swiping through people
if there's someone that you find that
you particularly like you can in scroll
down go to their Instagram click through
unto their Instagram so it opens DM them
sent message then go back on a tinder
swipe left so that they never see you
and never find out that you found them
on tinder then continue the exchange on
Instagram now obviously what all of this
that particular exchange is dependent on
is the fact that you have an Instagram
which at least shows some form of value
and that works for both guys and girls
like it if you even if not you still
will come across as less of a creep
having an Instagram profile and evidence
of friends or evidence too so absolutely
you know you're immediately rated a book
the best person on to the worst person I
Instagram
rated above the best person on tinder so
we've got in this so I've been through
that I've done that with tip with tender
I've got five or six people on Instagram
there's two problems now one is if my
instagrams just photos of me like nah
then I'll probably struggle but also I
have to say the right things to them so
this is a wash your mind surround feed
look like so I said this on the how we
get them love island video and it's that
your Instagram particularly because it's
quite surface deep quite transactional
very easy to see it visual right like
Twitter and Facebook is a little bit
more nuanced because it's micro blogging
whereas when you looking at Instagram
it's like window shopping images right
yeah exactly so Instagram is absolutely
no representation of your value but it
is a ubiquitous internationally
recognised form of social currency and
it does represent some degree of
popularity now that popularity might
have been gained through the fact that
you were once in a porno or do you know
like any particular reason oh you want
to part of the race scandal god knows
what it might be but you can't you were
recently part of a race scandal with the
the anti-semitic stuff and you're
talking about the Chris Williams an MP
yeah yeah that's really good those yeah
event of the of all of the politicians
stratum of my head of all the
politicians that I can share a name had
to choose the one that started hating on
Jews yeah doesn't happen very often that
you get anti-semitic politician but the
problem is I he's been in the news like
three times in the last 18 months and
all of them have been from bad reasons
it was a hashtag about just hash tag
Chris Williams education like you know
poor yeah so he got someone got his
Twitter handle some someone called Paul
Sherlock had done something in the u.s.
like something really critical critical
it's like a UK journalist it's a start
tagging Paul saying I'm gonna write
articles about let's see yeah be careful
with what you call yourself what your
birth name and then you all need to be
careful Twitter and then some so um yeah
with regards to the Instagram thing like
I think that you do people do need to
think about the way that they come
across online let as well you might be
someone from the old school who says I
prefer to meet people the old way it's
that well that's great but you have to
spend an awful lot of time out and about
just in looking versus how efficient you
can be on your phone especially the fact
that you can essentially be dating
this is presuming again presuming that
somebody actually wants to find a
partner and you can be dating on your
lunch break I mean browsing around
messaging people and putting in
groundwork so to speak so that you you
know progressed whatever relationship is
there to the 90s where you don't you'd
go out to a coffee shop and just speak
to people on your lunch break
well I mean it's like that's if it the
the interesting thing as well just on
the note of like the image that you're
creating on Instagram is what you said
about like if there's multiple photos of
them just lit because I think there is
no greater creep stamp than photos of
someone in the house on their own
because it's just like or a series of
photos of one person in lots of
different locations yeah you see some
people that all of that profile this is
on Facebook like people their profile
photo is about ten and it's always just
them either in their room or in
different places
slightly sullen slightly as than the
happy it like a magazine isn't it or a
brochure of you but again like this is
you know if someone can say well that
you know [ __ ] now I'm not using my
Instagram is a shop window for me like
that's fine but you need to concede that
if Instagram was part of your lead
generation they would yoga which is what
which it can be like again good dancer
fine you don't need to do Instagram you
can do whatever but if you want to give
yourself obviously you know eighty
twenty eight cover all of the bases to a
degree and it's not hard to have a good
outward representation of you say see I
like the photos of you pushing your mate
down the street in a trolley pissed or
like you battered at your grandma's 80th
like that probably keep them off and
stick to the ones that are well lit and
okay look
nice so my main point here in the whole
thing really about the Instagram the
Instagram funnel it's just that you want
to have some form of high immediate
value that other people can interpret
and I think the reason that instagram
has become this really interesting
social currency is that it is a game
that almost everybody's playing so - the
same as when you watch the Olympics you
watch Usain Bolt and you watch how fast
he runs
everybody has run pretty much everybody
is wrong and you're like holy [ __ ]
[ __ ]
I've done something similar to that and
he is the best in the world at it the
same as when you watch people that
really strong people watch like
Strongest Man is on every Christmas
right like primetime channel 5 because
everyone looks a big stone and goes
[ __ ] I love this like I'd ride - I
tried to pick up the shopping the other
day it was really heavy so those people
are competing within a domain that other
people can interpret the conversation in
the office Johnny how much do you lift
300 300
that's like 300 bags of sugar I always
get on Christmas always get like how
much can you do on that how much can you
do on that because yeah I'm not strong
man I don't weigh - nor kilos I don't
use a lot of anabolics I'm not on TV not
Maverick not that much in comparison oh
how much laughs you can give them any
number here you can say 10,000 oh that's
like three of these so because I have an
Instagram yep and I have 400 followers
and I see someone's Instagram that has
5,000 followers and lots of really
polished photos and say wow this person
good shopping - therefore is popular
well you've got so it's so everything
yeah right and this comes back to
account if the first thing that said
which i think is really virtuous
actually that a lot of people would make
fantastic potential partners the only
problem is that you're not giving them
the chance it's the marketing yeah the
they're literally dilatory just
marketing themselves poorly or maybe
you're marketing yourself poorly so it's
like right well if you present yourself
online in the best possible way and if
everyone else does as well then you're
giving yourself the best chance of being
accepted by whoever whichever potential
partners it is that you're up to I
suppose all Tinder's doing by allowing
photos and content on there is is a
almost like a template if I look fill
this in fill it fill the best stuff in
and this is a mini version of Instagram
isn't it and everyone has that but
that's all in the context of I've
created this to try and get day or get
laid well think that's the least sexy
thing about any exchange between two
single people is one of them obviously
knowing that the other ones after them
mmm and tinder precludes that
immediately yeah that makes sense it's
like you just chops off at the knees any
coyness about the exchange because I
have the [ __ ] we like you we both know
why we're on here which is good for the
very utilitarian like I've got time for
any nonsense but anyway they're just
like right okay I get that power often
even with that in the exchanges
backwards and forwards that you have on
tinder they tend to be so like vapid
that's why everyone's just like you see
the hole I'm just on here as a joke like
oh you're just not really serious like
people trying to qualify that they're
not really that serious about it and to
try and communicate that in short tinder
should only be used for legion get them
on Instagram then use that for leave
conversion okay there we go
and when it comes to that like really to
be honest that is about as far as the
Instagram funnel girls like
there's no secret script to converting
from from there in Belarus there is a
thing there isn't there is an upsell no
there isn't
not yet um but really you just need to
develop some degree of charm online like
that so here isn't quite may be quite
cold questions so how many how many
people
leads does it take to get someone to
have a meeting off Instagram I realize
your numbers may be better than the
average person but is it we took because
obviously tinder like if I'm on that I
have an expectation at some point
someone's gonna want to meet me off
tinder right so I'm let's say does it I
don't know lo so I limp one in ten and
what am I gonna expect one in twenty one
thirty one it's not a missile on
Instagram it would be lower leads lower
volume leads high volume conversions but
you need to screen more carefully
because not everyone single right what
are the factors that influence
conversion so you've mentioned total
number of followers are your photos with
cookie rated feed and then just feed
literally just compatibility so I think
really it's new we can try and create
this semi autistic framework for the
authors think you familiar fully
automated we can try and create this
kind of framework for it but like I feel
the YouTube comments already like on the
last one when you're comparing women to
the second-hand car market no we're not
comparing women to the second on car
market I'm preparing relief in the
condom and like you've been slapped to
do be valid but yeah like you I don't
think that there is really much that can
be done so I suppose what I'm what I'm
getting out of the question is if you
stand in a supermarket and try and sell
people something versus if you go out
and knock on people's doors and try and
sell people something it's a different
experience because one of them I'm there
to buy things the other one is like I'm
in my home myself like if I'm just on my
Instagram and someone messages me
because tinder is very much like the
Facebook feed where once upon a time it
was just people posting [ __ ] like
further themselves now to get attention
it's like attention bar up in our eyes a
leadership because we're trying to get
attention to people open with stupid
[ __ ] on tinder ins and you know have all
these attention grabbing headlines
that's what they used to on tinder you
obviously can't do that on Instagram or
if you try to you're gonna be like I'm
across very I'm gonna ring the police
because people aren't expecting that on
Instagram they're expecting like well
hey how are you
the other thing is all to consider is
that no one I don't think anyone really
can have too many friends
and just by messaging so when you might
actually end up making a good connection
there is a number isn't there there is a
there is a good Martha Martha
Dunbar's number 250 that's like how many
friendships people can actually made
supposed to be how many connections
inter played connections between
different social actors within your
consciousness you can hold on to at one
time and that's supposed to be the upper
limit of what our tribe size would have
been when we with nomadic people moving
around but having spoken to William von
Hippel who is like king big dick on this
maybe I can rusty Ripple he didn't he
didn't have any you know he he said that
realistic upper bound was 50 because if
you've got a tribe of 250 people at the
bottom have no chance of rising to the
tops that you'd split off and make their
own it's too big so you have multiple 50
times it around about that it would
appear that between kind of 20 and 50
was more realistic but yeah I mean also
any promoters they're listening you know
that that's bollocks I'm able to what in
my heyday I was able to have like a
thousand people and then because that's
when you're pushing it and you're like
you have to start creating systems to
maintain ism but so apparently as well
off the back of the 250 thing seeing a
friend or touching base with someone
every 14 days apparently is that the
minimum interval that you need to
maintain take the French imagine if
Johnny went really hard on his digital
detox that's 30 days we're no longer
friends
we do Ducal new pods digital detox won't
allow no friends all right he's no
friend trying but it's not it's not one
strike in your life I feel like if you
notice what stage is it yeah left have a
word with raspberry ripple so anyway so
hubby I'm gonna go I'm gonna go back to
just more now we've moved on from the
Instagram full-on thumb [ __ ] I'm just
talking more of that no you just like
this cuz it's like is no no I like it
because it's what everybody wants to
know well so anybody who's seen I think
I how much I can three vyas episodes and
nervously OH
so you you're a popular guy with women
yeah you surprised yeah so and I imagine
other people will have will have
observed that uh-huh so fight against
the by was of an invisible corridor
amazing yeah so that's what people want
to know like if I'm a I'm a single guy
or a single girl and I I'm single 21
year old horn horn Laden my oh oh
everybody everybody get Tony
and I'm struggling with tender loving
crap results and this is a relationships
104 how ready for addition how does he
single how do we see the map of how to
be single you know simply exist online
like I think that again the synopsis of
this first section is in my opinion that
you need to try and find a domain of
competence or a domain in which you
represent or you present as much value
as early as possible as quickly as it's
possible and that means like if you like
CrossFit girls let's say let's say that
you like really fit girls if you get all
men for now like in seriousness do you
think this domain of competence and the
social proofing strategy applies as much
in both ways that because I remember you
asked raspberry ripple this which was
our the reply is yeah like it is social
status as much of a coveted feature in
male to female attraction as it is for
female to male so I think as we've said
it in the previous episodes the typical
direction of the protagonist
a dialogue goes male to female and males
tend to be the actors and females are
like the maidens right that's just
typical hmm um so I think girls
essentially just get better conversions
on everything they're just better at
lead gen they're better at conversions
like because if the initial stage yeah
now moving forward in relationships is
they actually that probably gets
reversed so you can have a wider initial
market but then actually converting them
into a proper boyfriend they've got a
proper boyfriend as a girl probably
gonna be a little bit more difficult
rationally speaking statistically
speaking you would assume that's because
she's getting all the practices in there
you'd assume that that's because women
receive more propositions than men yes
so like if a man receives five
propositions a year and he knows he's
ever gonna receive five propositions you
he's probably gonna say yes quite a lot
of them literally suggest that women
have that's why because the bottleneck
is wide at one point an arrow at the
other and you flip whereas if generally
receive 50 a year they can afford to be
more selective without going through
periods if I also think that that is
genetically just the way that we tend to
be wide as well hmm that men will go
wide and shallow and we'll all go narrow
and deep mm but yes I think glass say to
book em that you need to try and find
some domain within which you present
value and also yourself in the best
possible light that's a if you like
girls do CrossFit like get really good
at CrossFit and spend some time in a
CrossFit gym like if you if you get
really good at CrossFit and you rise to
the top of the people within your gym
you are presenting yourself in with a
lot of value in a domain which they are
competing in and the reason that I think
or the reason that I'm proposing the
Instagram is a fruitful Avenue for a lot
of people to do is it's a domain that
almost everyone can Peter agreed
everyone understands what a thousand
followers in 10,000 followers in a
hundred thousand for and this particular
kind of Imogen etc etc this many likes
in the photo again these aren't like
judgments on your genuine value but the
point is they're a metric which allow a
quick judgment exactly and all you're
doing is getting a
across in the best possible light also
if if you take the that's the average
twenty-something who's left uni now
works a job maybe goes to the gym or
CrossFit or something goes out on the
weekend struggles to meet someone they
like in a club there's no one they like
it work like where are you gonna find
that person cuz because I think this is
a big trap for people it's not where the
same routines you've maybe had a
relationship you need that failed or is
no longer there you're looking moving at
your late twenties looking for someone
to settle down with but like who is that
person
so it's how do you find that and that's
why tinder or that's why these services
become an option is how you use need to
be in contact with more people don't you
it's difficult it's difficult one so
yeah that's that's that section I
suppose I think what yeah exactly thank
for that
what am I to kind of move on to is just
strategies really for being careful
about who you actually choose to date so
red flags yeah big big fat red flags
anyone who is I mean I were just walking
through a minefield is it's delicate
right but whatever like [ __ ] people
people get cross with us all the time
yeah it's fun but no DMS are open as
always you just get dropped in the
funnel if you message about it all
that's gonna happen is dukkha dukkha
dukkhata for you know you want to date
with Kristin you don't even know why so
I think for safety the the first thing
to do is to identify red flags in our
own gender and then and with it also
what we haven't done is gay 101 or gay
we're waiting we're waiting alone I've
got a cup of potential good eloquent I'm
excited for that because I just want to
find out to learn more about I want you
know how you know if you're a bomber or
a balmy yeah that's a question
everything was that is a question like
is that it do they have a frank
conversation about it I think that there
must have some form of written agreement
waiver I don't know what do you get a
signed I know so you told us if those
this bottom or top thing right was it
you told us this grinder that are
whether they list themselves as well I
don't know I don't know if the
developers have put like a field in the
in the profile you should be but
yeah it would maybe but you can't get me
both I know I know in that bazaar how
many feet the thing is as well if you do
get that and you have two bottoms
nothing happens it's like two negative
polarities on it Magnus just pushed
apart trying to push yeah it's not gonna
work and so I think some things I can
think of that you should be careful of
if you're a girl looking today to die
especially so let's presume that this is
you actually starting to like
prospecting with the potential that this
might turn into something more as
opposed to simply being purely
transactional like if it's simply being
transactional make sure these safe
obviously like do maybe a bit some form
of background checking if you're going
around to the house tell your friends
why you're talking like if you go for
the first time taser it taste it yeah
peps break to sign up with Experian Pro
you can run credit checks on other
people so just a bad joke
just to clarify with regards to that
like just to someone you're attracted to
basically but yeah if you're looking for
a little bit more as a girl I think a
really good question to ask you guys
when was your last relationship and if
they wanted to be recent or not you just
wanted to exist just data okay like if
it's if it was if it was I would say if
it was within the last month or more
than the lack more than five years ago
it's been there nine they're held hands
with my with my girlfriend yeah nine
years old
temptation eject eject eject the
difference nine hours ago nursing
there's a Goldilocks 9:00 at night
yeah older than nine years old but
further further away than my nine hours
ago yeah there we've got the rule of
noisy sweets from the river nine so I
think that's what about you guys do you
think there's any other things to look
out my red flags with men so the the
main thing is and this goes for both how
do they talk about their ex
and yes there is a chance that their ex
was this massive psycho that but even
then there's a level of tact and class
that if someone just downplays it or
doesn't tend to go on about it or if
they have any generalizations about
women as a whole if you have someone who
it just seems bitter about about all
women like that's another like he brings
up the red pill stuff yeah yeah
particularly red red who's got any rollo
tomassi books I don't want any of that
what does that what's red to red
red pill whose role on this there's two
new kind of online movements for people
is it super three so you've heard of in
sales that was in the news recently like
voluntary celibates people who are
celibate but not through their own
choice so they've they facing they're
virgins and they want to not be virgins
but nobody will have sex with them and
so they then funnel line to this
bitterness for all women and then now
they're the kind of people that you see
the occasional like ambassador of the in
cells that does like one of the school
shootings and you know but lack of
affection
so if quite a dark whole red pill is a
similar on prompt like if anyone's
matrix related well so the rest of the
red red pill red pill as far as as far
as I'm aware is a equivalent male
opposition to the feminist movement
which puts kind of male values first
right and it's exactly that it's taking
the red pill instead of taking the blue
pill so that you see through the facade
of what the games it's specifically that
games like hypergamy a female hypergamy
dating up and across like things like
that and these guys tend to use pickup
artistry strategy and they have quite
militant ideas about how you should deal
with women and stuff like that like
Rollo Tomassi book the rational male one
of the rules that he has in there is
never let the woman be in charge of the
childbirth so it's basically like if
you're not using a condom you're a
[ __ ] idiot
if you're another one of his iron rule
so he's got I think it's ten iron rules
one of the Aisne rules is never lived
with a woman unless you plan to marry
within the next six
months a whole bunch of other one so
it's quite a very very hard lined mail
first perspective which 8-core is just
protecting men from being hurt by women
what actually ends up manifesting itself
as men just being really [ __ ] bitter
like crazy weird crazy bitter I mean if
you just if you want to go and have a
read of this like illimitable man is a
pretty good example of this and in that
there's this dark triad of if you read
this is he the one who wrote the article
but mark mode yeah so [ __ ] great so
it's really for basically it's it was
this blood blog post that I think you
wanna go yeah and it's about like how do
you how to focus in your life and
there's like do monk mode for a few
months thinking over like isolation
intensity shut off social media again
there's all about like basically
productivity tips and how it like really
W awesome and it's like oh great I
wonder what else this guy's oh yeah you
just open up this Pandora's Box it's
like you need to develop psychopathy
like novices and narcissism and this is
something else the dark triad of like
these things so anyway to move away from
that like you think that our suits are
the three movements yes so we have red
pill we have ourselves and there's an
old man called mg T ou W men going their
own way and I think there's a level of
knowledge that you to have about this
[ __ ] it's about time in the inside yeah
its Twitter there's a few of these areas
on Twitter they're like okay yeah
comment number and it's it I think so so
to summarize these movements it's it's
kind of a very month extreme masculine
reactionary quite quite woman-hating
approach okay so cuz I think so there's
obviously there's even you wouldn't find
yourself on a date with something like
this anyway know that you you might do a
really common yeah its death well with
an insult like not because as soon as
that happens they left the house yeah
they're out there at night so I just
think your point that was be careful
about the sort of blogs that they read
in the books that they talk about and if
they have this kind of
overarching woman-hating mmm rhetoric
that they put across that's not and I
suppose the problem is it's not it may
be subtle or it may be it may be overt
but that's you know and it may be also
directed towards a woman in their life
if they talk about their mother in a bad
way or their ex then I like the fact
that you've said that there's a degree
of class with which you should be
speaking about you you acts especially
on as well like if it's because we're
talking before you're in even anything
that's seen someone like within the
first first few dates are you speaking
to them online or having a phone call or
a FaceTime with them or whatever it
might be that if one of the openers is
that [ __ ] [ __ ] like if that's that
if that [ __ ] [ __ ] ever comes up then
I think just exit immediately yeah block
get out yeah exactly which is also
another good thing about Instagram just
block so yeah there's no upside to
talking ill of someone that you no
longer with but also even if they were
terrible even if they were truly
objectively terrible and you talk about
them neutrally civilly and respectfully
that can only reflect well on you so it
was why I think you're signaling to the
other person they're never gonna go
really fancied him because of how badly
you talk about sex yeah and if you're a
guy who does have residual feelings
about their ex then use this as a good
canary in the coalmine and just don't
don't mention it like if you can't like
the old adage if it counts anything nice
to know because there might be something
but it's the whole like does protest too
much but also there might be some people
that would be trying to do it to almost
like try and prove that I'll know I'm
over her because I hate her but even
then he is quiet is quite a strong
emotion and so you thinking about the
absolute ultimate way and George McGill
a tweet something about this a few
months ago and it was like the ultimate
way to prove that you think you're over
somebody is it indifference it's exactly
what you want you want to see them walk
by in the street and feel nothing no
bitterness and no happiness like just
hello it's a test to see if you're your
rebound as well as know like if someone
is speaking
emotive lien aggressively about their
previous relationship chances are it's
not fully out that I've achieved you as
if you are the rebound you're you're not
they're not seeing you for you that is
just getting entangled in a previous
relationship I mean you know we both or
all of us know people who appear to just
pin ball around and from different
relationships like there's a lot people
yeah well that's what it is it's a great
image isn't that this is just there are
some people who exist that can't bear to
be on their own and I'm aware that I'm
jumping in ahead of you here but the
this is for guys and girls there are
people for whom they can only feel
comfortable in a relationship I remember
so this is a story that I can tell it's
like outside of the NDA of relationships
which is a decade stories more than ten
years old so a girl who had been with
another thing the 10-year rule amazing
have Megan listen my first one I've made
it up it isn't my world Christmas being
with being with a girl like just seeing
it on and off nothing too serious but
anyway back and forth back and forth and
we decided that I decided that we were
going to end it and she got a little bit
emotional about it and then got even
more emotional side kind of been a
little bit hysterical and said something
to the effect of I really don't want to
break up because I don't want to have to
go back to going out all the time and I
was like hang on what what I don't
understand what you mean he says well
like because I'm not with you anymore
I'm gonna have to go out all the time I
was like why won't because I'm not with
anyone I was like oh my god I'm seeing
this frantic desire to not be on the
road not be on your own
play out in front of me an overt way for
it to happen
I like Wow like that's a very dangerous
situation to be if so an alternative -
when was your last relationship I think
also a good question to ask would be
when was the last time you were single
and if the last time that they were
single was for two weeks two months ago
wasn't the last time for all that
if you can't bear to be on your own
Daniel saw said this in the episodes
link will be in the show not too low
advice I'll make it appear as a good
podcast [ __ ] unbelief woman just to
trust 20,000 views if daniel said like
if you can't learn to love yourself how
can you expect someone else to love you
and how can you expect to be able to
give yourself across to them the best
that you can so you don't know who you
are so there you go like spend some time
on your own and if that person hasn't
then they either will have a poor
understanding of their self or there's
someone who is pinball ball well it's
just there's just a lack of an
independent thinking and way of
operating as well like if someone is
relying on you for everything on a day
to day basis you know I are you've made
plans on Friday but I haven't got plans
so I don't need to do anything that's
sort of situation like that
I can't think of anything worse to be
honest then without being in that
situation but I think that can often
result from people who haven't ever had
to make plans in the room on a Friday
because it's always just been staying
and watch lost or whatever it's a
dangerous that's another dangerous one
that's not the same my memory is lost
[ __ ] really dangerous and finished it
awfully who's all the dream whatever the
dream was it that was that was a
finishing yeah it was all just like this
special heaven place that they've made
to be with each other that's such an
eight-year-old finishing nothing
finishing a story and he woke up and it
was yeah because the thing was it looks
like he got towards halfway through the
final season and you were like [ __ ]
our dice like this there's eight hours
of programming left and um explain the
polar bear you haven't explained why the
plane came down you haven't explained
why everyone that's dead keep coming
back you haven't explained that young
and it sure enough it got to the end and
we knew like just got to be a big answer
there aren't a lot of individual answers
here and the big answer was like it was
all a dream like a so I gave up after
the first season
well you've missed nothing bigger
there's the answer and in fact Prison
Break so that's a different a different
situation to someone who loves to be in
relationships is someone who doesn't
want you to be a part of their life
but wants you to be their life and that
is a very dangerous partner to get with
as well yeah but actually actually how
how on earth do you find someone who
isn't a complete psychopath
all that we're doing here is just Ruger
can't be with him and can't be with her
and they don't work and this one's awful
so we need white flags as well is that
the opposite of a red flag and white
flag is often seen as surrender Green
Flag green flag green flag green light
good color yeah so I have some warning
points first okay cool so alright so
this is more just like a personal
frustration is guys who play the owner
and we're just friends
root and then so let's say you're trying
to get get with someone goes on whatever
and that girl has a mate who's a guy who
is like just there for advice and may be
quite critical of you for whatever
reason who then tries to swoop in at the
last minute I think they are some of the
most dangerous idiots because there's a
straight away it's very vulture like
they're not up front with our intention
it's difficult the road I would watch
out first personally I just I've seen
the situations that unfold unfold that
haven't worked out very well so it
should based on physical past experience
I would say that you know if someone
wants to be with you in that way they
should just say I think it's difficult
to um like it's the age-old question if
can guys and girls just be friends and
you're like yeah they can but if the
girls in a relationship and the guy's
not the person she's in a relationship
with difficult isn't it in just whatever
you opened up her someone's written a
list of red flags for women but I think
they're all twice accessed actually okay
alright let's just I think we better
skip them know people more people so
that was one second one was similar to
what you said I've just asked them how I
asked them about their mother because I
think the way that it's just you know a
woman in the person's life like if
they're very caring and speak very
fondly of them other chances are good to
win generally yeah chances are that's
that's a really really good
test yeah well yeah oh said thought to
green flags then myself I saw every I'm
I still need to do red flags for men for
women desert to a which is a woman yeah
yeah I would ask them about one or two
polarizing topics ideally in the media
at the moment and just see where they
sell you give an example so something
something like like the Liam Neeson
thing would be a good example so
something that is like you know where
people just have like I said clever
soundbite to say so like that have a lab
a brexit sound white that they say or to
reason a sound bite but ask them
something that like pushes a moral
button just see what they do because I
think that's when someone's caught off
guard you analyze them just deal I gonna
do not since either who's Theresa May in
which case run Eve yeah or what's for
exit mm-hmm but like you know but what
do you are unlikely in recent think what
do you think about that and obviously
like that that's something where someone
will just say other opinion is just
about can they formulate a yeah if
there's something reasonable I think are
and even if they don't know
can they with grace play off the fact
that they don't know mmm like I'm not
really into politics like but I can tell
you a lot about travel or II enjoy the
one just say I don't know I've not heard
about that what's that yeah for example
yeah cuz a very masculine thing is that
iOS will that do higher okay but yeah
are the brexit stuff yet oh yeah I was
reading but I fit male answering
syndrome like oh I I wrote the book on
bricks in money bricks it we went out
for drinks
it was probably brother used to play
football
alright okay and so what will show the
month on Korea clip and see if they
react tonight which is very good it's
positive grab we talked about that last
week they're like embarrassing things
you've said when you were younger about
our know thyself
I've got 12 ounces at home 12 ounces no
you haven't
and we weren't talking about that uh
where you talking this the life fails
raspberry anyway so I want to do what
about what should
guys look out for red flags in in women
there now which restraining is slightly
more dangerous territory but its
territory that I am incredibly familiar
with so watch me tiptoe with finesse
through the minefield I think I know
what doing I think you and I are
probably safe in the things okay I'm
excited yeah so just as a as a
disclaimer here as a disclaimer like you
two are fairly successfully like
continuously monogamous people right
yeah like you in other ways you see me
as continuously monogamous but in the
last 15 years I've been in a
relationship first five of them right
but in the last seven years last seven
years in a relationship for six of seven
but only five to fifteen you just you
just pick the time so currently you're a
successful relationship you're a CEO but
you both serial monogamist to one degree
or another now me so background for
girlfriends took up from 18 to 25 and
the longest period of a single was four
months right and then with just none
then another three-year relationship
after that all right but the vast
majority of my life up to now has been
with me being in a relationship and just
you know fate for me I've I've never
this is gonna sound arrogant but I don't
I've never like ended a relationship and
then sort the next one things just tend
to before you are successfully to see
really when I get monogamous those yeah
yeah anyway so what what we what do you
think red flags yeah so loved ruffles in
it okay so I I think the most important
thing is emotional stability without
question how do you judge though so very
difficult to judge so
the reason I say that is inevitably
you're going to end up in an argument or
discussion or disagreement over
something and if that can be managed as
a in in a sensible adult conversation
chances are it'll last an hour then go
away again if that becomes like well
like [ __ ] you I'm taking your car and oh
you know like this is over and I'm
leaving suddenly is spiral into
something massive so emotional stability
is a big one in terms of how do you
assess that path specially early on as
well having just by field
what's the like breasts yeah field oh
and see whether anout would kind of is
it if they're firmer and high I know
so I mean what was that thing that you
said in one of the podcasts Yousef where
you're like it's really easy to convince
anyone for 20 minutes that you're not
psychopath
yes like an early on in a relationship
anyone can convince anyone that they're
not an emotional wreck which is like off
I think job interviews are a terrible
way to assess somebody because of
exactly that reason yeah if anything if
you are a psychopath you are the best it
makes a game you've got no empathy I
would disagree with the emotional
stability thing though okay so it's
definitely my preference and I think
it's your preference
mm-hm david deida talks a lot about
sexual polarity and the masculine energy
energy and saying that if you are a true
she right
third stage man you should be like fully
navigating the fields of having a woman
who's like really emotionally labile and
being able to ride those waves and okay
and fully like enjoy in saying that the
more the more of that there is like the
more attests you as a as a masculine
spirit and it helps you to to grow and
to like allow allow your relationship to
flourish through that just I think quite
trying yeah I think I'm just not
somebody number three goes to that I
don't think anyone is I see that sounds
like an unnecessary situation to be in
Johnny Johnny got me to tell you about
the best analogy that I came up with in
a sauna via their own views of corner so
the emotional instability
you just said that it's exactly the same
is so good it's you can imagine that so
this is like the analogy for having like
you have like a normal discussion or you
come to a conclusion for something but
there's all this turmoil an argument in
the meantime that was just totally
unnecessary just to come to a decision
that so what input is what we doing
tonight
output is that's me to 8:30 but in
between that there is this crazy
back-and-forth an emotional turmoil and
fighting and all the rest of it is
exactly the same as you putting your
trade on and and the market dropping by
50% for it to bounce all over the place
and finish 1% up in the green any like
what the [ __ ] was that
yeah what was this bit here and you're
gonna manage how you feel about all of
the emotion all of the [ __ ] don't
trigger your stop-loss because if you do
if you treat your stop-loss the
relationships over it's exactly I will
challenge anyone out there to tell me
that's exactly it all just comes back to
Chris coffee I saw him in caffeine you
know you want to go at you and go to
restaurants and running joking oh really
okay
so I'm I love it yeah right we're
talking about people it's not about them
so I guess I'm so emotional stability
just allows for efficient outcomes a
great week there's a second thing as
well wasn't that that was a first one no
you said though there's two things
emotional stability and maybe maybe that
was anyway what about you weird
so for I don't have any red flags for
women not thinking anything bad that a
woman could be give me some time to cuz
I mistook this because I've just seen
that listen I'm trying to not say
anything on that list I mean so for me
the again the main ones for men also
occur for women I do they have a life
outside of that
partner do they have their own interests
that on friend group are they able to be
independent do they demand your time
over activities that they know you
really value like if you're saying oh no
I can't see you tonight I've got play
video games then that's probably not
tremendously justifiable if it's no I
can't see you tonight I've got training
for this upcoming weightlifting
competition or I've got football with my
friends that I only do once a week or
I've got to see my parents or I've got
to do something else which they know is
of genuine value T and that is the sort
of thing especially because we're
talking now about the as my mum and dad
would call it the courting stage in
which the leveraging of all trades is at
zero like there's no magnification there
shouldn't be any overreaction really to
anything because there's no
justification on either side yet like we
have not even more sensitivity to the
smaller change of rebels because people
are on their best behavior and so you've
got to then be more tuned in to that
going absolutely definitely agreed like
you if they don't have your best
interests at heart and if you don't have
there's a heart then that's immediately
a sense that you know even on a minor
level you think my thing are well that's
within my tolerance fine I'll leave it
but actually it could mean that when
things are magnified after they take off
the mask I think that they're much more
vindictive and that they're actually
willing to trample on you you need to
what you need to watch for these things
super careful yes but especially earlier
what about stuff like you know people
stress a lot about how often to message
how fast to reply after after a meeting
who wrote me messages I think that that
is such a waste of mental space sorry
lunch aways and if you feel like
someone's doing that doesn't get around
the fact that it is actually a little
bit of a nuance to point and it is to a
degree quite important because frequency
of reply and learned and who actually is
the one who's the pimp who's the
protagonist and it
is the one of the main things there is a
video from school of life Alain de
Botton again he's just the king at these
little aphorism kind of Maxima type
things and talked about why we hate
people or why what when attracted to
people who like us and it's because it
feeds in someone who is aloof naturally
gives themselves some sense of being
above and beyond and out of our reach
which naturally we push towards like if
someone if you put your hand on
someone's chest new push their natural
reaction is to lean into you so that's
exactly what happens as someone pushes
hard you you tend to push back harder
against them because you kind of don't
really like what's going on unless
they're a judo master and they can just
they're just Taekwondo even in the floor
yeah so yeah I think so that's why I
like that I'm not gonna reply because if
I reply now that I seem I don't see
tookie-tookie let's prepare the worst
thing as well is that I know for a fact
that there's been a turn-off for me with
girls like girls who are not one keen
enough which isn't the same as being too
keen not mean enough they're
insufficiently young keen they
insufficiently aloof so they get you
know that they're not aloof enough
they're not now sufficient if you want
to make it on that and it's a single
just a single linear no not the key when
you're saying they're not far enough
over this direction yes
all of us however the problem is and the
reason I'm saying it's a waste of mental
space is that as soon as you even start
second-guessing your own like oh maybe I
shouldn't reply then you being keen
again because you're trying too hard
it's the same as why like the whole
pickup artist you think only works for a
short period of time until people
realize actually this is just a really
desperate guy that's tried to like
micromanage all of this I disagree okay
because
because if they truly didn't care they
just reply as and when they saw their
phone which is the pickup artistry the
pickup artistry thing is you changing
the core of who you are as a person what
I think and again this comes back to the
reason for using the Instagram funnel is
that you are wanting to get people over
the hump of that very first bit to
convince them that you not mental yeah
and I think that a lot of people would
there would be a lot more good short
relationships if everybody was
presenting themselves in the best light
I think a lot of people make a lot of
really basic fuck-ups like and that's
not to say that I don't i but al are you
advocating that they are inauthentic
with no no I think that what you need to
do is just retrain yourself to be not
mental and not to keen like if your
response rate is within seconds all the
time and you quadruple message all the
time you have to concede the fact that
there's some people that will be a
turn-off so also if you can see the fact
that if you don't message it
sufficiently frequently it'll be a
turn-off but I think that though
inevitably as with everything the
virtuous mean there is something in the
middle so it's the same way as you would
go to a job interview wearing a shirt
and tie even though you don't
necessarily want to because it's about
signaling to that person that you're of
a certain order and a seat I see where
it tucks it's like we're the [ __ ] you
didn't if you go into job is so so how
they have a just have a rule with your
cell phone
generally do you agree I wanna say like
I so I apply after after the first day
I'll reply after 36 hours or whatever
and then you just don't think about it
because I think people get stressed
because they're they think something and
then they second-guess what they thought
and then they second-guess that the
worst thing this is the thing I think
one thing that actually has occurred due
to the advent of whatsapp and other
instant messaging services like that is
that back in the day you can see when
people around but back in the day
texting would
there's always this culpable deniability
about I didn't read it yet yeah it's
like [ __ ] off mate
I've seen you come on and offline 20
times I remember having a conversation
with you when they when they released
the blue ticks on what's up of like this
is gonna cause problems this is gonna
cause arguments because he used to be
able to turn read receipts off on our
message or have them on do you remember
when you might have never had snapchat I
knew you do have such a remember when we
used to have top friends on snapchat oh
yeah people would really fall out like
letting you imagine how many
relationships that's rumbled because
snapchat particularly is like when we
get like this in a sword Onew or that
little streak yeah but that's it in the
fire flame
excuse me yeah so like if you see that
someone's got and that with what someone
else then that didn't exist anymore to
you safe um have you come up with
anything and is it so I bet in your
examples when you're saying someone's to
keep no it's insufficient me button
click on key yeah that they probably
just do it without thinking and even if
they're not even if the that doesn't
truly represent them they've done
something like so I think one of them
especially now that the response rate is
less of a concern or less of a major
factor because of the advent of instant
messaging the content is like if it's
what are you doing tonight when are we
going out next like you can you can talk
quite freely backwards and forwards and
keep it casual you can also talk quite
for I think sarcasm and a little bit of
kind of giving is a good tactic to be
able to keep everything playful not only
does it stop you from falling too deep
into the like falling in the early
stages of look for someone of you've
only met a few times it also kind of
it's that playful territory that like
you can't have that once you've been
with someone for like six months you
can't give them about not really being
that bothered about what and I mean I
[ __ ] off me it was a procedure yeah
produce whether they know everything
whether they can take a joke as well and
that's it so if I think for me the red
flags are yeah can they take a joke are
they have they got a sense of humor so I
think that pre frames a lot of other
things a lot of character traits what
there's not quite laughs then there's a
lot of other things wrong with them
it's like pre-screening for particular
yeah
downstream genetic diseases and
something that isn't that too bit sick
disease just am isn't it triage it looks
like the blood pressure measurement so
take the blood pressure
what do you symptoms what else you take
the heart rate it was it very long for
masturbation so then you want to do a
skin swap you're in dipstick there's
still sample on them no so that you made
it to stool sample that person's a
keeper yeah you see one you've seen
their blood listen I've got to screen
with you with my I just got a few tests
it's just from you know must peace of
mind if you can just doing this yeah so
there's the laughing test they also like
diligently for stupid things like if you
do a puff-puff do they do they find it
[ __ ] the kind of man I'm gonna I'm
gonna hold my hand them yeah here I have
never been and this may speak to the
degree of the death of relationships
I've been it never been in a
relationship where I've been comfortable
to fart in bed the same I think it's
amazing thing to do to someone if you're
in bed as well as to Dutch oven them
burn Dutch oven is really for this
trivial ad so I just I don't I'm not
sure that's a comfort thing I think that
like in the same way that like I I would
just slap yourself assault on something
yeah what they do it is you're in a
long-term relationship now and you live
live with some how do i navigate
fluxions yes so it's not something that
i really think about i don't think i
have that much really
so the trick I've heard is you go into
this is if you're on a date and go into
the bathroom and you get your bum above
your head so you make sure your head
lower than your bun so that the air
because the air is gonna rise over the
link
it and so then you percolate the
puff-puffs over the liquid over any
others
anything else in your bowel so that you
can then get it out quickly but the
problem is a lot of the time people say
well by the time I walk to the bathroom
it's got room and it's basically up
there and your night burka far too early
right now you need to fart you go to the
toilet maybe some reason invert yourself
why can't why don't you screw the toilet
in front it looks you have to be in hip
flexion as well to fart well no it just
accelerates you don't to be in there for
20 minutes trying to like crack this far
yeah you just you want to be you know
because otherwise they'll be liable he's
gone for a poo and then you have to go
well I wasn't doing at Rob's why don't
you go I wasn't pooing I was just fart
always be on the toilet and just
contract as hard as you can something
will come out no you do great I won't go
I don't know because I think if you try
and pull when you don't need to really
good luck then you know this issue a
half of one and this problem anyway that
the second green flag or red flag is
before we don't know which is it
don't say we'll be in flag all right
like then say something else imagine if
it was waving the plane in did that like
one green and one listened to the flag
in Ulan you both understand why it can
be both okay so how they treat the
waiter again this is a minor variants
that will over time
widened and so if they'll eventually
leverage and you'll be able to see so do
they treat the waiter rudely or nicely
same for taxi driver bus driver yeah a
train conductors this so anyone that
they don't have anything to gain from
and they're you know are they generally
civil and respectful to other human
beings do they say waiter
does a waiter oh wait excuse me who did
they call them Carson or like oh yeah if
they yeah yeah
if they do a double I think of every
season so we'll do that that us yeah
that's a very issue to tipping no so
don't not all fiscal policy isn't
included so with with paying for a meal
I will always pay on the first date
if it's if they offer to split I'll
always say no more if you steal if I
step what if they offer if they split no
if they split me you steal then then you
take it all and then you find your time
seeing the prisoner's dilemma comes game
theory that's when you say can I go to
the toilet and then you run out the
window yeah
so if they if they offer to and
interesting with is there's a dating
coach from women that did a video on
this and he said it was really famous as
well yeah it went viral he was like if
using this memories like alright ladies
he's in the room about 250 women who
thinks the man should pay prematurely on
the first date everyone was the hand
open is like okay and who thinks that
you are obliged to sleep with the man
whenever and however he wants no one
puts the Honda things like well that
doesn't match up because what you're
saying is that your time is worth that
is worth more than his and that he
should have to pay for it and then
you've instantly sent unequal basis for
the relationship one is one is having
sex with someone yeah and I see what
he's getting at as who he's getting at
so but he was implying that like what
you're all doing is like prostitutes do
that they say that time is worth more
than and so yesterday he's like unless
you put yourself on equal footing with
the man from the beginning then you are
so I said so for me personally I'll as a
man I will always at the first meal turn
to be like oh I'll get this done when I
got I got bodies if that I know for a
fact in my heart parts if that girl
forcibly said essentially this [ __ ]
no way that's happening take off with my
money I'd be like hmm it's great I think
you someone who Hardison pushes in that
brilliant it's not just a fiscal policy
with things like that it's like if it
was who's gonna drive who's gonna do
whatever like does it just having a girl
I found it like incredibly attractive to
have a girl who's very forthcoming about
these sort of things
like if the same reason I think why
female athletes tend to be attractive to
a particular kind of man because you
like well I know that there is a very
protagonistic independent forward minded
mentum kind in the theme to what this
one it's a lot of money it's about the
the attitude did they see you as an
equal and do they have the command to be
able to yeah okay so so the way they
treat the waiter the waiter only may
choose to split or steal and then the
the push press thing was that you said
the father yeah it was a third one
anyway there is also the the old story
the old adage about the guy that was
talking to a couple of guys in the pub
and he was like me I'm a behavioral
psychologist I can I could tell a lot
about you from a single thing terms of
the first guy is like Tommy
do you have a goldfish and the guy was
like yeah and he goes oh well okay so
you've got a goldfish that means you
live in a relatively stable house that
means you've probably got a dog as well
you've got a pet you've done this tracer
that all right and that means you're
probably married and that means a new
young and so you probably haven't got
kids you probably were quite an active
sex life and so you don't masturbate
guys like so the goldfish is a real
green flag green flag green flag but
that means they're married yeah so if
you catch they've got goldfish and
they're not married there's no wedding
ring so what you're saying is look for
indications of stability yeah if
stability is something you're going for
uh suppose well I don't think anybody
wants an unstable instantly unstable
manage that
wake up every day and just be absolutely
attract a rounded life with every
possibility it's just a bad boy versus
stable man
that got to me doesn't it highly highly
fluctuating market man if Derek J wide
about it right he's got both his bad boy
is like every every woman i watch so
what is it everyone wants a once a man
who is able to come home and play with
the kids and impressions singing songs
sing songs about the little kid doesn't
know if he wants to be a bear or if he
wants to be a rabbit or whatever but
then also if he needs to can go [ __ ]
some people look at a parking lot and go
Tom Clancy Rainbow six so I really
strongly agree with him because he who
doesn't want that
mm-hmm what's it what's one bad thing
about that what do you want from it in
the equivalent way though what you want
from a woman that you want them to be
able to good [ __ ] Rainbow six folks
and people probably the woman on a date
and she she runs out to the parking lot
because for Tom Clancy's up some Rodgers
you'd be like I don't I wouldn't have
the same like over that so sexy I'd be a
bit like how would you definitely be a
little bit aroused I just feel it was
stronger or more physically capable than
you then I need it like that I think
that's inexcusable or not I do a drain
what's on the stronger strong negative
particular reticulum certainly powerful
part and in particular movie yeah like
in terms of absolute strength there is a
you know probably can't pick up more
weight like it's just that lift isn't it
if you seem the liberal through female
bodybuilders episode they're not that
strong you see the husbands of the men
who like what's more yeah they're always
like very patient I really like them I
think they're like goddesses and they
just like you do foot stuff yeah plus
they're photos of feet yeah they're
definitely leaves what stuff there is
lots of p45 effort not p45 8:45
firing which is loads of employment
documentation around them in tax forms
and self assessments specific fetish
climate on an essay three or two right
so we've got whatever you know we had it
gone done that gone done some
relationships is there anything else so
like I guess finding people you need to
just you made a great point that if
there is no one within your particular
sphere it's what was it the he referred
to us within your consciousness that
just area within your Elsie well you
didn't your life you know the sphere of
influence that were you mean so the
answer to that is the same way that like
affiliate marketing works so what I mean
by that is you want a certain type of
person so you think what what does this
person I read listen to watch spend time
doing attend etc and then just go places
well that person might be there you go
so yeah that was my point that if you
don't have someone within your life at
the moment who matches what it is that
you want from a partner you need to
expand into that and online is a really
easy way to do that yeah well online is
just really online is kind of like an
index tracker isn't it hmm
it's like placing all the going long S&P
yeah but I forgot to go buy the shares
and get the certificate and sign it off
and I know these anyone anyone that
won't that says like I don't want to do
online dating is like you can say that
and you can think that but you'll lose
but you are doing online data if you're
online you're doing on someone who's
like you know I want to go to coffee
fitting advanced people like you're just
gonna be outplayed by the guy with an
Instagram funnel who's doing this its
scale or the girl or giving up on we've
emancipated is what is it when you do it
to link when you see musculature no
emancipated the emancipated like the
male only Instagram funnel now has been
the gift has been given
all women in this worth if I held in it
I get put into a woman's Instagram
funnel it might be the most erotic
experience in my life and hurry - sure
so you might be in many I might be at
the really bad though other conversion
rates terrible I say sir they need to
split test more yeah I would love for
someone listening to this to think I'm
gonna put Chris on my phone successfully
they go get past the if you ever being
funneled I don't think so
my open rate is my my cuz you get lots
of masses requesting because that's the
problem with the Instagram from he's
unless the requests are maxed out on a
time guard
so it's either they have to actually get
from message requests into inbox to
emails chance of but so that I suppose
someone with a large Instagram following
harder isn't it yet they're gonna have
more message requests and you're gonna
go into the noise you basically go in
the spam folder and you have to be taken
out with essentially another point that
this is really important I can't liver
didn't say at the start if you're gonna
actually message someone because you
think that they're an interesting person
and this goes if you're messaging for
guys or girls use their name mmm like if
you just say higher and put an emoji you
if I was like instant spam bot if they
if this is generic message yeah like I
would say oh my god ,
have you seen this question mark oh yeah
or if it's about one more to seem what
are you more likely to open on you but
if there's no other messages I'll just
think it's messy so I can you request
you wouldn't think like wait until the
next message I feel like they're gonna
send another message here I can't
believe what this is laughing emoji but
there's no there's nothing in there you
but the whole point grace is to create
intrigue it's not openly you've not been
single for ages of it how do I'm giving
everyone tips of how do I stand out and
Chris's in MoMA I'd see all of you power
lifting videos and think I don't want to
be with a man who's Ron only Chris I'm
not going the message e from the propane
and cigarette with oh my god have you
seen this thing get upset when you night
or go on a date that's not what this is
yeah I'm thinking I'm someone listening
to this
I won't think I want to put Chris in my
funnel now yeah what can I say to stand
out in Chris's maxout thing so what are
people saying you need to psyche risk he
put me on VIP hi Chris I won't guess
this honestly the best the best way to
get oh my gosh look at it have not seen
this yet I've told a piece I've said
this a number of times the best way to
get an open from me on Instagram is to
complement the podcast okay if you
complement or share the positive it's
actually the best compliment would be to
say oh my god have you seen this know as
they've got to this point in this
episode oh yeah
true now it would be closer no they
still they still need to compliment it
but that is a compliment that's the best
comment or underhanded it's - okay I bet
you open I might do thank you very much
do not forget thank you thank you more
do not thank you thank you as well use
it do not forget to press subscribe down
below and please share this episode we
want to land in the top fifty worldwide
again and in two weeks time worry about
what it was that we said yeah exactly
okay bye okay pardon
[Music]
you